انتهاكات ونص صارخه حتى وان حاول النظام
الايراني اخفائها او انكارها تبقى الصوره
دليلا ومصمه توفق مطال المحتاجين من عنف
وتنكيل منذ اكثر من شهرين عاده اصوات
متظاهرين وصدحت بها شوارع ايران صوت بات
صده مسموع دوليا منهم من مدد بتجاوزات
السلطات الايرانيه ومنهم من دفع بقرارات
لكبحها
العقليه القديمه لاصحاب السلطه في مجابهه
الاحتجاجات لا تنفع بل على العكس فاقم من
الاوضاع نحن الان نواجه ازمه على اعلى
المستويات على الصعيد حقوق الانسان في
ايران
ناقش القمع الدامي للتظاهرات التي تهز
ايران وافضل الى اقرار مبدا فتحي تحقيق
دولي بشان الوضع في البلد
[تصفيق]
الدوليه التي دعت الى تفعيل سريعا لاليه
التحقيق والمسائله فيما تعرض له الالاف من
الايرانيين ووقف اعمال القتل خارج القانون
والاخفاءات القصريه والعنف الجنسي الوضع
في ايران يستدعي قرارا حسما بانشاء اليه
مستقله لتحقيق والمساءله بشان ايران لجمع
وحفظ الادله على الجرائم المرتكبه والتصدي
للافره من العقاب وارسال رساله واضحه الى
السلطه الايرانيه مفردها ان جرائمها بموجب
القانون الدولي لن تمر بعد الان بلا رابع
منظمه
الايراني لن ترضعه مجرد تنديدات اللفظيه
وان الوضع المتفجره في ايران يحتاج وردته
فعل حاسمه ينبغي لمجلس حقوق الانسان الامم
تسليط الضوء على قمع متزايد وان شاء الله
لتحقيق في انتهاكات الحكومه الايرانيه
ومحاسبه المسؤولين
رغم نكملها لي من الادله التي تدين النظام
الايرانيه بالجرائم المرتكبه بحق
المتظاهرين والتي دفعت اعضاء مجلس حقوق
الانسان الاموي بالدفع نحو الموافقه
بتشكيل لجنه تقسم للحقائق حول قمع الامن
الايراني الا ان السلطات في طيران تواصل
عمليه الانكار وتتهم الدول الغربيه
باستخدام قضيه المحتجين كاداه لاغراض
سياسيه
روان حمزه العربي